it's nice for me to be meeting you oh
look at these fantastic gentle while I
destroy humanity okay cool I love your
special best time of our lives thank you
for saying that
can I take your jokes from here yeah you
could take all home SSSs SSSs hahaha oh
my god I find you're special you get
directions from the custard when can I
live on your feet oh I don't know is
that cheating only if she finds out he's
got a broken eyelid he's got a broken
toilet yeah it was wiggling he was doing
some he was poor things stroking out a
little bit muscles I make up for in
height and sex appeal are you mocking
excuse me you're talking shit what do
you like about me it's an explosive
weapon that uses the exothermic reaction
of an explosive material to provide an
extremely sudden and violent release of
energy Jesus Christ that was terrifying
she just turned to talking about bombs
out of nowhere what I didn't say bomb
did I say bomb I can't wait until this
until she just turns on you she's like
what do you say bitch what do you mean
I'm wrong as soon as you cut as soon as
you guys cut I'm feeling this robot up
but not on camera you won't catch me on
camera are you a fan of Adam Devine's
movies I'm not sure
well why don't you think for yourself
hmm why don't you have an opinion on
Adam Devine in his comedy stylings I
have no good answer for that how do you
usually introduce yourself I usually go
with like a hi I'm pretty direct I make
eye contact I noticed you just want to
stare off in the distance
how often do you just you've got a work
tester off that's one of the best ways
have you ever wore tester it off though
because you have to or work just
Rudolpho cool guy really good guy I
think you really like him I think you'd
really like him do you like talking to
me it's really fun just meeting new
people making up names same words that
don't make sense within the conversation
or Chester offered oof oh okay I guess I
have to ask you all the questions I'm
sort of like Jimmy Fallon and all of a
sudden huh I've got a steer this
interview how would you rate me on a
scale of 1 to 10 for overall hotness
1980 47 degrees Fahrenheit do you think
I'm fat sometimes okay I think we're
done here then I am not done with you
you